whatever programming language you
learned there's a core set of things
they virtually all have in common and I
want to lay those things out here as
quickly as possible so first I
understand that in all cases programming
is about data it's about analyzing data
with logic it's about transforming data
with logic and it's about generating
data with logic that is the essence of
every program and to be a useful program
every program must do what we call
output it must write data outside of
itself it must write data to a file send
it over network put data on the screen
to display send audio data to an audio
device that then gets played out through
speakers etc these are all forms of
output and if your program doesn't do
any output then it's a useless program
because it doesn't have any effect on
the world that any human can observe
programs may also do input they may read
data from outside themselves so just
reading data from a file or reading data
from a network or read data from human
input devices like mice and keyboards
and most programs do do some input but
it's not strictly necessary the way
output is because you could have a
program that just simply generates data
and outputs it without doing any input
now data can come in many different
kinds but the essential kinds which most
of the things have been made of our
numbers strings boolean's and
collections numbers require no
explanation but a string is a piece of
text it's a sequence of text characters
and a boolean is a value that's simply
just true or false which are used to
represent all sorts of yes/no pieces of
data like for example is a currently
sunny outside yes or no true or false
lastly a collection is a piece of data a
value which is made up of other values
which might be numbers or strings or
billions or even other collections and
there are many different kinds of
collections because there are many
different ways to organize multiple
values but the most obvious and simplest
and probably most commonly used is a
simple list you have a collection which
is just an ordered list of here's the
first thing here's the second thing that
there are the fourth the fifth and so
forth now as for actual programming
languages the mechanisms which they
virtually all have in common is firstly
they all have some set of built-in
operations they all have variables they
all allow you to branch with
usually what are called if statements
they all allow you your code to loop
with what are called usually while or
for statements and then they all have
functions which are basically like
operations you yourself define in your
code you have a small set of built-in
operations usually a few dozen and with
a function you essentially can define
your own operations and with just these
few mechanisms you actually have a
complete programming language the
question though is what about input and
output because none of these mechanisms
do either input or output
well we'll explain how input and output
is done in programming languages when we
get to the end so operations most
languages have a few dozen operations
and that will always include arithmetic
some logic operations and perhaps things
for manipulating strings to split them
apart and to join them into larger
strings and then a few other odds and
ends operators which differ from
language to language and each of these
operations what they do is they take
input values usually - for most
operations they do something with those
input values and return an output value
so examples include most obviously
arithmetic way or say we might add
together two numbers and it returns a
number the sum of those two numbers or
we might multiply two numbers which then
returns the product of those two numbers
but aside from arithmetic operations we
also have some logic operations what's
called the and operation for example
we'll check if two boolean values are
both true and then it returns a boolean
value that's true if they are otherwise
it returns a false value and then what's
called the logical or operation will
check if at least one of two boolean
values is true and it returns true if
that's the case otherwise it returns
false
there's also an equality test operator
that'll check if two values are equal
and return the boolean true if that's
the case otherwise it returns false so
say we can check two numbers if they're
equal or check if two strings are equal
and lastly for manipulating strings very
commonly languages will have a
concatenation operator which takes two
strings and returns a new third string
which has all the characters of the
first combined with a second after it
and be clear that concatenation leaves
the two original strings unmodified it
generates a new third string rather than
modifying either the input
and this is the case with most
operations most operations don't
manipulate their inputs they just rather
return a new generated value now in our
code we want to be able to store values
in memory and for that we have what are
called variables a variable is a named
location in memory which stores a value
when you create a variable you the
programmer picked the name of the
variable it can be whatever you want it
can be say Tom Dick or Harry or XYZ or
whatever in practice you should pick
good meaningful names that indicate what
is being stored in these variables but
whatever the name having created a
variable you can store a value in it
with what's called an assignment an
assignment takes a value and stores it
in a variable by overriding whatever was
already there so say in our code we
might create some variable named foo and
another variable named bar and then we
can assign the food the number of value
3 so we can directly assign new values
to variables what we can also do is take
the value of an existing variable and
assign it to another variable so we can
say assigned to bar the value of foo
whatever is currently stored in foo gets
copied into the variable bar and we can
also assign to variables the result of
operations operations returned values
and those values can then be assigned
into variables so say we can assign the
foo the value returned by adding 8 and 3
so then the value 11 would be copied and
stored in the variable foo be clear that
these variables in programming they're
called variables but they're not like
variables in mathematics in mathematics
you have variables in equations like y
equals 2x in which for all possible
values of X there's a corresponding
value of y and vice-versa what we call
variables in code they didn't know
storage locations in memory and at any
one time in the course of execution a
variable storing just one single value
they're called variables their values
vary because as code executes we can
change what a variable stores but at any
one moment a variable storing just one
value now as so far described our code
is just a sequence of statements
executed top to bottom and his statement
so far we'll create variables and assign
values to them often though these
statements of code we want to take a
chunk of them and have them only execute
conditionally so as code executes from
top to bottom in counters a block of
code a chunk of statements that it might
skip over based upon some
condition and that's called branching
and to do branching we use what are
called if statements an if statement
starts with the word if followed by a
condition which is some boolean variable
or operation that returns a boolean and
that's followed then by a body contained
within the F and the body is just one or
more statements of code so what happens
when our code executes is it goes top to
bottom and when it encounters an if
statement it first evaluates that
condition it looks at the boolean
variables and sees if it's true or false
or it performs the operation and sees if
it gets back true or false and if the
condition is true then the body of the
if is executed but otherwise if it's
false then the body has skipped over so
for example we might have an if
statement where the condition is an
equality test between the variable foo
and the number of value 3 and so if foo
stores the value 3 at that moment when
the test is performed then it will
return true and the body will be
executed but otherwise the condition
turns false and the body is skipped over
for another example you can have a
relational test operation you can test
if the value of variable bar se is less
than the value 9 and if so the body of
that if will execute otherwise it'll be
skipped over in addition to branching in
code we often want to be able to loop we
want to have a chunk of code that
potentially repeats some number of times
this is done with what's called a while
statement which is actually exactly like
an if but for one difference like an if
when the condition of a while
tests true then the body will execute
but unlike an if after executing the
body execution we'll jump back and
reevaluate the condition and if the
condition is true again it'll execute
the body again and each time after
executing the body in a while execution
jumps and tests the condition again so
as long as that condition keeps testing
true every time execution jumps back to
evaluate the condition the body of the
while will keep executing one more time
only once the condition tests false does
execution skip over the body of the
while and continue on after very
importantly we generally don't want the
body of a loop to X
cute repeatedly forever we don't want it
to be an infinite loop and so somewhere
in the body of the code it has to
somehow change something usually modify
some variable such that either in the
next test of the condition or in some
future test the condition eventually
that will become false if the condition
of our loop never becomes false then our
loop will never end and that's generally
not a good thing we don't want infinite
loops last thing to say about loops here
is that while statements because they
are kind of statement they can go in the
body of other loops and in fact of other
ifs so you can have loops within loops
loops with an ifs and in fact also ifs
within loops and ifs within other ifs
you can just
nest them arbitrarily as much as you
want generally though we want to avoid
our logic from getting too complicated
so it's generally a problem to have it
nested several levels deep but it is
something that languages allow lastly we
have functions a function is a body of
code which we've given a name such that
elsewhere in code if we want to run that
body of statements we can call or invoke
the function as we say by name and in
that place where we call the function
the body is executed in the body we can
do whatever we want and the function can
also return a value to where it is
called with what's called the return
statement we specify what value of the
function returns and this return
statement can go at the end of the
function or actually can go earlier than
the end you might have some branch of
code earlier in the function which if we
go down that branch then we return early
from the function rather than completing
the rest of the code functions can not
only return values they can also take
values as input and this is achieved
with what are called parameter variables
for the function you specify if it has 0
1 2 3 however many parameter variables
you want and then when you call the
function you provide an argument of
value for each parameter so for example
if my function foo has two parameters a
and B that means when I call the
function I have to provide two arguments
to values and the first argument is
assigned to the first parameter a and
the second argument is assigned to the
second parameter B and then in the body
of the function I can do
with those two parameter variables there
otherwise just ordinary variables but
special about them is how they get their
initial value anyway our functions can
take input and they can return output so
in a sense they are like operations a
function is like an operation which we
ourself are defining in our code
languages typically have only a few
dozen built-in operations but we can in
a sense extend the set of operations by
defining our own functions in fact in
most languages a program is effectively
a set of functions any function can call
any other and there's no code there are
no statements that exist outside of the
functions and program execution begins
by calling the function which is given
the special name main so a little
strangely your main function isn't
necessarily written first in code it's
not at the top of the file it could be
at the end of the file and yet that is
where execution begins and then from
there from main we can call any other
function and from those functions call
other functions etc be clear that when a
function calls another when main say
calls function foo execution of main is
in a sense suspended while foo executes
and only once foo returns this main
resume execution execution picks up from
where foo was called and if who returns
a value that value can be used as an
argument to another function call or as
an input to an operation or it can be
assigned to a variable or in fact you
can just ignore it you can discard the
value returned by a call lastly about
functions understand that their
parameter variables and any other
variables created within a function
exists only within that call to the
function so I might have two functions
which both have a variable named X but X
of one function is a totally separate
independent variable from X of the other
they have nothing to do with each other
they just happen to have the same name
furthermore when I call the function
multiple times if I call my function foo
multiple times each time it has its own
set of its local variables if it has
parameters a B and C and in variables D
and E every time we call foo there's a
different ABCDE the variable a of one
called a foo is a different variable
than the one of a different call to foo
they are separate variables a separate
set of the functions variables is
created each time the function is called
and
that set is destroyed in effect when the
call returns very less thing I promise
to explain how input and output is
performed in code well its first
important to understand that the
programs we write are run by an
operating system when your system boots
up the operating system code is loaded
and the operating system is responsible
for managing the hardware and for
managing other running programs when
programs want to read and write data
from input and output devices they're
not allowed to do so directly they have
to go through the operating system and
so through some mechanism of the
hardware and the operating system which
varies from system to system
but through some special mechanism
usually a particular CPU instruction
programs can invoke system calls which
are requests to the operating system to
have the operating system do some kind
of input and output on the behalf of the
program so say in my program if I want
to read or write a file my program can't
really do so directly it has to make a
system call to request that the
operating system read or write the file
on its behalf so the question is how to
invoke these system calls from our
language and usually the language has no
direct mechanism for doing this there's
no code you could write yourself in the
language that would revoke a system call
instead usually the language provides a
set of special functions that are not
normal functions of the language these
are functions implemented in a special
way that will invoke system calls and so
to invoke system calls you invoke these
special functions